Alright guys, so here is the example number two for this strategy.
So I'm looking at Euro GBP on 4-hour of course, and you can see we are making lower low, lower
high, lower low, actually no, lower low, lower high, and then another lower low, and the internal
market structure been creating lower low, lower highs for quite some time now.
So it is clear that the auto flow is bearish, I'm not going back here, I'm just looking
at the price here, okay, and as you can see we are making lower lows, lower lows, lower
highs, lower lows, lower highs, cool.
So now what we do have is this auto block, okay, of course this is hindsight, but you're
going to notice these, okay, so this is the candle and price goes back into our PUI, so
let's drop down to 15 minute time for them, and you can see that just over here we have
a shift in market structure, but notice what happened, the market structure shift did not
happen during kills on ours, okay, so the kills on ours are basically two, till, I got
seven, it's my bad, right, and then 7.30, 11.30.
For this specific strategy only, okay, 2am, till 7, that is your London, and then from
7.30 till 11.30 is your New York session, make sure you set your time zone to New York.
So now we're going to wait, okay, we are going to wait till this high is taken out again,
because this is liquidy now, when you have a market structure shift outside the kills
and the kills on ours start, which happens right here, you don't want to look for market
structure shift here, you want to wait for first press take out this high over here,
and then you want to look for a clean market structure shift, and that happens right here,
and let me show you how, we also took out this high here, okay, so that is a clear shift,
lower low, higher high, higher low, higher high, and then we have a market structure shift
during kills on ours, perfect, now this right here are our consecutive bullish candles,
and also look at this breaker block, it is in alignment with the auto block, and this
consecutive bullish candles becomes your auto block, right, so you're going to take your entry,
here, put your stop right above this high over here, and you go for one to two,
simple as that, let's go and see how this plays out, as you can see we got our entry right here at 645,
and you can see we hit our take profit, if we held that would have been a beautiful trade,
but we only go for one to two, so I hope you learned something from this example, remember if,
let's say that this candle did not take out the high here, and then you had a shift over here,
that is a low probability, low probability market structure shift, I want this clean
liquidity sweep, and then displacement, that gives us market structure shift, something like
boom, boom, boom, okay, this is prime, you have a liquidity sweep, right, and then your market
structure shift, and this leg has consecutive candles of the same color, so if I was looking at
here, I would love to see bullish candles take out this liquidity, and then a market structure
shift, and I take my entry from here, kaboom, so I really, really do hope that you learned
something from this strategy, and from this example, I'll give you guys one more example,